where the hell did you come from hey
youtubers is Charlie arrow season 2
premiered and we got our first look at
Black Canary that's right there's a
bunch of new characters villains and
heroes that are gonna be on this season
I'll talk about those in a second but
first let's talk about what happened in
this episode we basically found out that
Oliver had been hiding out on the island
since the events of Malcolm merlyn's
earthquake a bunch of people died they
weren't able to stop it in time so their
grief was a big runner throughout this
episode after David and Felicity are
able to get Oliver to come back you kind
of see some of the after-effects the
earthquake - the new group the hoods are
gonna be a bit of an antagonist
obviously the League of Assassins are
gonna be a much bigger villain this
season but we haven't met them yet it's
also hard to tell if there's a
connection between them and the hoods
but the hoods in this episode basically
kind of looked like they were operating
on their own select the title city of
hero implies there's a lot of vigilantes
now in Star City not just the actual
Green Arrow vigilante it turns out Roy
has actually been following in his
footsteps
we don't know exactly which episode the
red arrow will make his first appearance
in costume but Roy is definitely the red
arrow obviously the other vigilante is
the Black Canary so I'm expecting the
next episode identity that's the title
of episode 2 to kind of deal with her a
little bit more since she was introduced
in a scene with Roy I think his
storyline what kind of deal mostly with
finding out who she is but obviously
Oliver's going to run into her at some
point a lot of people thought that
Laurel would end up being Black Canary
because she makes a lot of vigilante
comments in the episode but it's
actually an actress named caity lotz her
characters alter egos a police officer
so in that identity episode I think that
will actually meet that police officer
person I did like the way they used the
flashbacks to kind of set up how Oliver
is really battling this murderous rage
inside of him he has this really big
guilt for killing all these people and
the fact that Tommy called him a
murderer for being the vigilante and
even Slade in the flashback actually
told him to hold back when Deathstroke
tells you you've gone too far you've
gone too far
district was actually gonna be a bigger
part of this season - so I'll be really
interested to see how he makes it off
the island so based on that they're
actually two big island questions who
else is on the island and how did Slade
get off the island there's actually this
new character played by Dylan Neal he'll
play dr. Anthony Ivo that'll actually be
part of the flashback sequences that's a
character from DC Comics and he
basically plays a villain and I think
I'll have something to do with the
League of Assassins
that's going to be part of the island
storyline but there were some really
awesome references in the episode
speaking of the island there was a
really awesome reference to death struck
at the beginning with that arrow through
the eye obviously the reference was
given in present day but in the
flashbacks he still has both eyes so
it'll be interesting to see how he ends
up losing that eye on the show because
there's an arrow through it so I'm
guessing it has something to do with
Oliver
I like the arrow cave it's just really
keeping more in line with the fact that
he's slowly becoming Green Arrow
he doesn't really call himself green
arrow on the show he's still basically
the vigilante but this season he'll
actually become green arrow so to speak
and in addition to that well actually
going to see the sinister six and there
are a whole bunch of new DC characters
but in the next episode we'll actually
see China white and bronze tiger again
Michael Jai White will be playing bronze
tiger the interesting thing about his
character is is that he doesn't really
consider himself a villain most of the
League of assassin people and the other
villains in this season actually will be
like that they'll basically be like
vigilantes that are just going too far
there won't be evil in the way that John
Barrowman scarier was evil that idea was
just kind of teed up in this episode
just being the line between justice and
murder so that's gonna be a big
continuing theme throughout this season
that'll be both an internal battle
inside of Oliver and a literal battle
between him and the League of Assassins
at some point
so speaking of villains Summer Glau is
obviously the antagonist in this episode
representing the other corporation
trying to take over Queen industries and
you know at the end they kind of left at
this checkmate position which I thought
was funny the idea of checkmate you know
our stalemate if you remember that
checkmate reference at the end oliver
making that white knight reference is
actually just a reference to checkmate
literally the organization in the DC
universe white knight is just one of the
leaders of checkmate so i thought it was
funny that he used that in describing
walter although i don't think that
walter in real life has any relation to
the checkmate organization so there's a
bunch of new stuff in an arrow season to
let me know what you're most excited
about and what you really like most
about this episode obviously i'm
expecting that most people like the
black canary reveal the most but we have
a bunch of new heroes a bunch of new
villains we even have some new ships and
a new arrow cave what are you most
looking forward to speaking of ships I
feel like the ship force surrounding
felicity and Oliver in this episode was
so strong that it was just leaking out
of my TV and a lot of interviews Stephen
Amell has said that Oliver kind of feels
like he's not worthy of being with
anyone this season but that doesn't mean
that he can't hook up either way in
other big news tonight I'm
a video for American Horror Story
covenant I'll be posting that video
tomorrow morning just because the airs
really late on television be sure to
subscribe to get it
I'll also be posting my Game of Thrones
Season 4 socially video tomorrow too I
just kind of had to postpone it just add
so many TV videos get out this week
Friday's Legend of Korra and Walking
Dead is coming back on Sunday so get
excited there's so much awesome TV
happening right now in the meantime you
can click here to watch my supernatural
episode 1 video and you can click here
to get all my agents of shield videos
thank you so much for watching
high five see you guys tomorrow